next bill is on the line hey Bill
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show today
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up honoured honor to speak
with you so I'm I'm calling about my 17
year old daughters been ready to start
her senior year school she's trying to
go to the local college here in about 40
minutes from our home when she graduates
from high school my wife and I are a
little bit of a disagreement on how she
should fund that school my wife and I
are Kirlian and baby step two and so
unfortunately cash flowing school for
her I don't think is going to be an
option for us but I'm trying to
encourage my daughter entire should also
probably mentioned that she's like my
wife's biological daughter I adopted her
so my wife has more influence with her
than I do
but I'm trying to encourage her to work
through senior year school save money
and then live at home her first year of
school and and work through school
trying you know cash flow herself so
that she does suck sighs whatever she
does is not able to pay cash for with um
with student loans and I'm not going to
lunch with scholarships so my wife is in
disagreement with that she thinks that
she should move on campus if my daughter
wants to live on campus and she thinks
that she should subsidize what she can't
pay for with student loans the
unfortunate part is that I said that she
has more influence with her as she's her
biological mother and I can't I can't
seem to convince my wife to see us steer
her in the right direction I was worried
you know I thought you said you and your
wife were on baby step two we argue okay
so your wife wants to get out of that
but she want your daughter to get into
it correct and and doesn't make sense
our absolutely I agree with you but my
wife her position is that she thinks
that she can earn learn the value of
work and and get a higher paying job by
going to school and getting you know and
just as sacrifice you know to make make
higher salary later on down the road
well the problem is that's not true
mm-hmm
yes college graduates as a group make
more than non college graduates but
here's the problem
54% of people that start college finish
right 46 percent don't mm-hmm and they
all have student loans right I agree
with that and her tuition costs are
going to increase well not tuition but
her housing costs are going to be about
$13,000 yes so really what she's paying
for by living on campus what she's
borrowing money for is not an education
to get her a better job it's to live on
campus right it's a social life
absolutely
so we're borrowing money for a social
life I I couldn't agree well I mean like
that so your wife's point is not valid
absolutely you know if she can honestly
look at me or look at any sane person
and say my daughter should borrow money
to live on campus we would look at your
wife and go really or your parents
cousins I mean that's a dumb statement
who would do that nobody would do that
and you got to really break it down this
way mmm what this is is you have an
emotional seventeen-year-old that is
driving the lane on this not the parents
absolutely angry and emotional 17
year-olds I mean I had a sweet little
girl call me the other day and she was
over in South Carolina and she wanted to
go and pay out-of-state tuition in
Mississippi and I asked her why she
wanted to go to Mississippi there's
pretty houses in that town right I heard
that call actually yeah makes you want
to shoot yourself that tells you that 17
year-olds don't need to make decisions
by themselves is what that tells you how
long has this child been adopted by you
all three years I've been hurt I was
just step father before we get married
for eight years okay all right so she's
well aware that you love her
absolutely and she you've been the
provider and so forth here so I I don't
accept that your vote doesn't count in
this and so here's the thing I think you
and your wife need to get away from the
emotional 17 year old and talk this
through very very very carefully right
and say here's what you're really doing
you're really borrowing to live on
campus and that's not smart
Gregory anybody says that smart is a
goob and you know your wife wouldn't say
that if you put it to her that way I
mean she really wouldn't she's not a
goob so you know she really is smarter
than that but what is happening is this
kid is wagging the tug that the kids the
tails wagging the dog that makes running
the asylum sure and that happens because
man they they're very convincing they
particularly the girls I mean they're
very convincing on getting daddy and
ever getting their way with everybody I
mean guys are a little thicker you just
go no and they go home okay you know but
girls you know it's like all this drama
and crap around all these decisions so
we went through it I mean one of mine
applied to go out of state and I asked
her you know how long she was gonna I
was going to be not being the family
because you know we're going to exile
her from the family
it was 14,000 bucks at that time instead
of 6,000 further pretty much the same
stinking school you know just it happens
to be across a state line right you know
show me you're getting value for this
that there's an ROI on it we'll talk
about it for a minute but you know all
this is it so my friends are going there
which is how people pick things my
friends are going there what a dumb way
to pick a college and you know that it's
going to determine the education that
gives you your future now you pay for it
and you guys need to the two of you need
to be the adults in the house and lead
the child and I really push on that dude
because that you know you're making good
solid decisions here but you got put
outside the circle of trust
I agree with that and you gotta get you
gotta get the kid back outside the
circle of trust she she is divided and
conquered the biggest problem for me is
I get a little bit emotional when I
start talking about it because I'm very
I'm very Dave Ramsey you know gung-ho
and my wife is on board as well just not
as Ben Hill as I am and so the emotion
shock comes out when I am having these
conversations with my daughter and you
need to not do that you need to go back
with your wife and get aside and go okay
here's the key salient logical points
and it's going to be we're going to put
your arm around your sweet girl because
you don't need to make decisions by
yourself we can tell that by the
decisions you're making
and so we're going to help you with this
but it has to be there's no way with
teenagers if the both the parents don't
gang up on the teenagers there's no way
you win you've seen that on other stuff
actually with that when they divide and
conquer man they rule everything it
happened at our house - we raise
teenagers we all of them lived through
it we didn't kill any of them but there
was consideration at times okay hey
thanks for the call dude open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that is a really good call it's a
really good call that Bills doing there
and he's really trying to do the right
thing so let me just shake give a
shout-out to all of you out there that
are strong good parents the number one
reason we have a student loan crisis in
America today is the parents are wimps
my child wants to go to $52,000 year
school I make forty thousand and have no
money but it's his future and he really
wants to go why cuz they have nice
houses in that town what you know no mom
and dad you need to put your arm around
junior and help him because his brain is
not fully grown and you need to help him
make good solid decisions you understand
what 35 and 135 thousand dollars worth
of student loan debt looks like when jr.
is 32 years old married and has two
crumb snatchers and nails I mean it's no
fun it's no fun
I have to work because I have to pay for
this mistake I made where I finance the
ability to live on campus or finance
going to school I couldn't afford and
moms and dads you need to step into your
17 year old your 18 year olds life and
tell them no no well they have the right
to go do it yeah they do but they don't
have to have your support and so no
we're not sending money no we're not
emotionally supporting you and no we're
not financially supporting you if you're
going to go off and be 18 and stupid
that's called running away that's what
that's called your own your own baby now
now that we decided okay now oh you do
want our help oh okay
then that means we get input into this
decision and we're going to help you
choose a school that you can afford and
the definition of afford is you can pay
for it we can pay for it the plan
we put together between you working us
working and saving and you getting
scholarships can pay for it that's the
shoot school you choose you will never
regret that well if I go to a better
school or I get a better job really find
me one piece of research that shows that
there's more CEOs of Fortune 500
companies that graduate from state
schools than prestige universities study
Wall Street Journal there's research
showing the opposite is true this is the
Dave Ramsey show